(upbeat music)
(cheering)
- Alright, let's close
out with a great story
from the world of social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(cheering)
So it's dry January, the
time after the holidays
when people try to cut back on alcohol.
Good luck Shelton.
But cutting back doesn't mean
you can't enjoy a night out.
Here in Manhattan there's a bar
dedicated to sober drinking.
It's called Hekate, and they
even serve craft mocktails.
Super cool.
We have the owner on the line.
Say hi to Abby who watches
on NBC New York everybody.
What's up Abby?
- Hi.
(cheering)
- Hi!
So you say it's a great time to be sober.
Why?
- It's actually the best
time in history to be sober
because there are
hundreds of products now,
not just one near beer,
but hundreds of alcohol free products
designed just for people
who've given up alcohol.
- You're totally, I remember
when I was a waitress, oh,
many years ago, it was
like Buckley or Buckler.
There was like this one beer.
Yeah, yeah, there was this
one beer you could get, yeah.
I was like, oh man, you're driving.
I was like, anyway.
Well, what's on the menu?
- We've got all kinds of delicious things.
Our bestseller is the Healer,
which see how purple it is.
People love to put that on Instagram.
And that doesn't try to
be any alcoholic beverage.
It's not imitating an
alcohol-free beverage.
We do have spicy margaritas
and virgin pina coladas.
So there are drinks you'll recognize
from being in a regular bar.
And then we have a lot
of products that are just
stand on their own as something
that never had alcohol at all.
- Yeah, fancy fun drinks.
I like it.
That's fun, it looked like a fun drink.
Looked like a good time in a cup.
Well, thank you so much,
Abby, this is so cool.
And also it makes it easier, a
lot of friends that are sober
and it makes it cool for
them to go and hang out
and still have a good
time and still feel like
they're like a part of it in
the same way, that's very cool.
- That's why I opened the bar.
It was, I have a regular
bar right across the street
and a couple of my real,
real regular customers
gave up alcohol for
sordid and sundry reasons
and I thought well, I
need to create a place
where there's a sense of
community and a sense of fun,
but where there isn't the
temptation of alcohol.
So that's what this is for.
- Oh, that's super cool.
Thank you so much, Abby.
I'm liking your post right now.
And that's not all, ma'am.
Our season long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of Precise,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you, ma'am.
Just great ideas.
So they're gonna,
they're gonna be putting a
thousand dollars in your tip jar.
How's that sound?
(cheering)
It's one hell of a drink.
Thank you, Abby.
Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Jodie Foster, Sherry Cola, Derek and Nico.
You have a great day and
if it's not, change it.